welcome to this video about round nine
of the Olympian plate today so I caught
up with my schedule here and this is
some the most exciting round yet I must
say very spectacular round and also very
important for the overall standings um
let's go quickly to through the top
results here I'll keep the best for last
yeah Ukraine beat France and do all of
pursuing team's 3-1 Poland against
Azerbaijan ended in a tie to two with
her job of losing his first game against
water check Amina beat Germany two and a
half one and a half and I will say I was
rather disappointed at the end because I
think and after about three three and a
half hours
it simply looked like Germany would win
this match or at least tired and losing
it was really a bit of a letdown at the
end
Dani Friedman by the way the German
champion playing on board for year only
one yet another game for fantastic
performance he must be clearly above
2800 performance iam yeah then China
beaten the surprise team of the
Philippines three and a half and yeah
finally we come to the the match of the
round and maybe the metro for the whole
tournament so far the USA played against
Russia Russia wasn't elite before this
round and pretty much if they would win
today against the United States it's um
it's very close very close to being the
title but it turned out to be a really
really amazing match where I picked them
as you can see already here the game and
I can war against kramnik turned out to
be an amazing match I can tell you the
results of the other bought some ore for
there was Yakko Benko playing ray Robson
the youngster from the US and yaqoob
anchor1 fine game at the end he has a
brilliant Olympiad coyoacán played the
draw against only shook and there was
the end this was always thinking within
the drawing margin
yeah then come scheme he played them
both or two against Greece shock we
shocked having a good tournament so far
and Kamsky actually managed to win this
game with black with an elegance defense
really surprising Greece shocked in the
opening I guess but at the end it turned
out to be in a tough endgame battle
where at the end Kamsky got Luke and
Brooke against Luke plus a bishop
so the well-known ending which is a draw
and the books and of course those guys
also know how to hold it but with 30
seconds increment on the clock
yeah Grisha broke down at some point and
lost the game so it all depended on what
one the bots 2 to 4 well one one and a
half tied so this mentioned a camera
from Nick is some the deciding the
decisive one year for for the USA Russia
match so let's see what happens naka
opens with 90 of 3 crumbling Knight f6
and g3 which is an interesting choice
showing that Nakamura isn't in for some
theoretical battle with complicated
prepared lines but rather wants to play
a long complicated maneuvering kind of
game and maybe trying to complicate
matters later their chronic plays g6 and
yeah in recent times he tends to
surprise people I think usually I'll
move d5 would have been mandatory for
him just play like his usual solid self
but ok play g6
it's of course a fine move but it's
Cygnus signals his intention to those
are for some sort of Kings India and
Greenfeld or other more a symmetrical
structure so c6 so it would be green
felt most likely and we got it wound
felt gianchetti rune felt was 65 when I
come around elected to exchange on d5
white has got alternatives he can also
play more complicated like be three
young lightly to stuff like this but 65
versa
yeah tried-and-tested mainland and non
early 93 here black can also um Castle
and after 95 we got another main line of
this opening which for years has been a
favorite of Kapil played some very nice
games with this this wide structure but
here Kramnik immediately ceased the
opportunity to play nightly for himself
and this leads to and a change in the
pawn structure as we see that can work
at Queen b3 my checking the pawn so
black took here and now we have a
different own structure this Knight
maneuver with yeah with the time loss 94
93 but it helped to give like some point
of attack in the c3 pawn is somewhat
weak and can be attacked but like later
yeah
castles and the immediate 92 which is an
interesting move I think a good one also
immediately attacking d5 some black has
no big alternative C cavity spawn with
e6 and now he from opening up the
position of course black doesn't want to
take on e4 which would ya help white
with quick development and the knight
would be very nice on e4 also booth like
Knight Bishop g5 or Bishop 83
with potential invasions on these six
could be very irritating so black
doesn't want to take and he used some
little technical trick to play knight c6
um white would capture like has this
intermediate move attacking the Queen
and he can actually retake the corn
just one move late and um yeah doesn't
lose it so white didn't take on d5 it
wouldn't be nice strategically anyway to
take down
so um he just canceled and after Knight
a5 returned with the Queen the Queen now
in the long term wants to switch to the
King side Queen c7 now attacking in the
pawn and Queen f3 of course just
protecting c3 um yeah white could also
play other moves like like this for
example also not bad I guess but okay
wants to put the Queen um on the Kings
side then I played b6 very logical with
Bishop to to a6 as a possibility
why detect the rook on D on f8 which
moved away and now he 5 close in the
center and now we see a white long-term
idea he wants to play on the Kings side
but black just has one defender with the
g7 or bishop and wise has ideas with
pushing the H bond or maybe regrouping
in the night of the bishop for the
bishop towards the Kings side so black
has I think a fine position with this
point of attack on c3 this is just a
weakness and black should be perfectly
okay here
also please then let me know that the
clock times are bogus I didn't find a
version of the game yet which has proper
clock times I'm sorry alright Bishop a6
rook e1 it was attacked after all and
look see it yeah all this looks very
logical
push it before protecting the pawn now
black plays Bishop to h6 you're tickling
this night a bit and it doesn't have he
has such great squares now come where I
just retreated with the Queen to to
cover the night and we're close to a
very interesting point in 96 from
Kramnik Bishop a3 it was a tec-9 a5
Bishop b4 96 yeah and the problem is
black simply threatens to take on before
I play Queen c2 so white cannot make any
any kind of move so let's say we play h4
just for argument's sake the black will
take and then invade with the Queen
Queen c2 would be good also Queen c3 the
possibility so wide really needs to move
the knight and after here needs to take
care about this this pawn yeah the
logical kind of result here in a way
would have been the draw with Bishop
before and 96 but Nakamura this is
really admire well he just played Knight
back to be 1 and this is of course a
risky move it can't be a particularly
great concept to hood to to retreat the
light to be one but he'd simply wanted
to ward the draw and fight fight on and
I think at this point it was also very
much necessary because of the team
standings it was some I think at this
point rather clear that Robson would
have problems against Yaakov anko this
position and also it didn't really look
like from like that like that Kamsky
would win so
I think he just needed to play on a bit
also from yeah for the team so a good
decision but it's important that players
actually makes this kind of decision
sometimes you see teams playing
unsuccessfully simply because there are
some Hmong yeah some concerns of players
for their own rating or for whatever but
not for the team and yeah did you see
that Nakamura really wants the team to
win so it risks quite a bit a bit of his
own success iam ok black played out b5
which I don't really like but okay from
Nixon he knows more about this game than
I do
I know I I don't really like b5 him okay
his idea is to play probably 96 and
before breaking up the structure so that
the Queen can actually enter at one
point on c2 but still I am I don't
really like to to put this Bishop
offside on a6 then there were
alternatives like hood could have played
all kinds of stuff iam I'm trying to
regroup here with the C file and and and
others let's say move like here with
this idea Queen to d8 and release is
having something like this I don't know
I sort of like this more but it wasn't a
mistake or anything with it just like I
wouldn't really am turn to this move
against b5 I know I can grab finally get
something going on the kingside H 496
the mentioned plan with before and now
Bishop c5 he takes this opportunity to
improve has his bishop queen back to b8
and okay this has a concrete idea we'll
see we see later
Queenie to utilizing hit the spin so
that black cannot play before that
Knight a5
back and white gotten some knives back
into the game the antique romney girl
played very forcefully he just
sacrificed exchange on c5 which is an
interesting interesting move maybe not
objectively best but it's certainly the
most aggressive continuation and now
just queen c8 he wants to get it back
and then try to claim for compensation
because of the week c3 pawn possibly
also e5 could be a slide weakness
imagine Bishop to g7 Knight to c6 or
Knight to c4 that knee five isn't so
easy to hold Janna camera played Knight
f3 simply bringing the snipe closer to
the Kings side certainly a pragmatic
decision
Knight B 3 also was interesting
immediately attacking the knight so that
this kind of continuation would just be
winning for white just an exchange up so
black cannot take and in fact after a
move like Queen c7 covering this white
could turn try for something like this
with the idea of playing a four quickly
I think white should be slightly better
in this position with black certainly
has some some compensation you will get
c5 probably even in this zone this way
and it shouldn't be too awful for black
but white then I think must be somewhat
better certainly ok decided on Knight f3
playing more on the on the Kings side
and yeah kramnik now I took the pawn and
9h to yeah he wants to play something
like this getting the night into f6
and followed by by the Queen on the
Kings side chronic now played Bishop g7
which is okay just we treated this
in anticipation of Nigel and now
Nakamura played h5 yeah and here we have
the absolutely critical position of the
game where chrome Nagar made ya think
the decisive mistake really
I didn't have enough time to really I
put lots of yeah analytical power into
this but I don't really see them at the
computer also doesn't at least after a
quick check he doesn't see any big
problem with just taking here or let's
say any other move that it's not the
move played and which doesn't Blum the
material even just rooks eh it's a fine
move just increasing the pressure as
long as why doesn't ya get something
serious on the teen side or can play a
four with a good effect than black
always should be alright with the two
bishops and the good structure for the
for the exchange and the pawn of course
what he did in the game was the move g5
and this is really surprising to me
because yeah after other continuation
there isn't something very threatening a
parent and what white is doing now it's
not exactly witchcraft he just played H
sticks attacking the bishop took him and
queen h5 winning a tempo on the bishop
and having this in reserve so this is a
very natural easy to see continuation
probably and he miscalculated something
on the way because this is already now
very critical the Queen attacks the rook
winning a tempo and White has the very
quick attack by g56 Anderson this is a
thing yeah close to being lost already
click knight c6 now and yeah Knight to
g4 what should I do now he cannot really
am
anything else now then Queenie seven
probably maybe you can you can play some
yeah some computer like move King f8 and
trying to somehow survive for this it's
not not a very welcoming prospect though
what can also just play off like let's
say here attending a forum intending
maybe use on this diagonal it's it's
just no fun black is simply in disarray
now on the kingside this this procedure
was g5h six just sped up White's play so
much it's simply it's simply too too
much attacking power now
he played Queen e7 and after this white
has a has a simple technical solution
wide exchange squeeze and played a form
yeah and this now is the big problem
like it's a checked on b5 white
threatens Bishop f1 with a pin on the
spawn and what should black play he
simply doesn't have anything better than
trying for some activity the kind of
stuff like you taking here
it's simply hopeless and then the long
run let's say rook takes Bishop needs to
move okay seven and this is just an
exchange for for absolutely nothing
so Kramnik in this position after a four
tried for some desperate counter play
and I think he did a marvelous job in
muddy muttering the waters and make it
difficult for my camera to winning he
played deform and the idea was after a
takes Bishop takes and rook takes a
seven the idea now of d4 was to simply
ignore the seven night now and push with
d3 sub black is going for here desperate
counter play with the depot
but it is difficult so Luke takes the
Sam naka to get D to rook t1 and Bishop
e2 this was the whole idea I might of
course has 93 - to cover the rook and in
this position black is a whole look down
but he still has got a little bit of
play with the D pawn so there's still
some some tricky points here
rook takes d5 seafoam and now H 5 likes
ideas play F H for this launch in the
Jeep 1 and then advance F 5 F form so
that at the end maybe this knight
actually has to move or maybe one idea
simply H 4 takes on h4 and you should f4
so black has some definite counter play
going my camera played look a seven and
now h4 like ramnik in this position here
like I knew I had an alternative he
played rook a to of course you also need
to think about rook e8 the Sun would
have been would have been and the
possibility the question is after rook
takes Bishop takes and I'm sorry
obviously first taking him and now
taking on g3 if this end game is really
winning
I simply had didn't have enough time to
check this I think it should be winning
for white in some way but it's maybe
very tricky
yeah if you have fun analyzing somewhat
weird end games this is one for you try
to figure out if black has some chances
to hold it I think it should be winning
really but it's not something I would
bet considerable amount of money on my
camera played rook a to I think it is
also maybe better it wasn't necessary
yet to commit to this end game which
might be winning but my
you draw and after this it it's more of
a technical thing he needs to take now
on detour on d1 otherwise why just takes
t2 and now we get this kind of position
which is of course comparable to the
other one but there's the rooks on and
the things this helps wide a good a good
deal yeah c5 pushed the C pawn and black
tried although all that there is
possible with the pawns to get some
activity and he managed to get in some
summary of tricks iam Bishop h3 rook c8
attacking the the pawn while of course
cannot play Bishop f5 or something and
give up the phone you really need to
keep the C pawn otherwise he cannot win
so all pretty pretty logical and for now
and in this position actually I think my
camera could have won somewhat quicker
but what he did was very nice at the end
so I'm not yeah I'm glad that he played
it another way because it was very nice
but yeah I think it could have won
relatively easily was route g5 check
King moves and now sec the ropm and at
the end it's night and wish up mate
and that pretty pretty easy form white
will get all the pawns and just has the
basic night and and Bishop mate this
would have been a bit easier but he
played King f1 the idea being that now
he has got a very nice blockade on these
pawns and will win in the long run so
what he did didn't spoil anything the
other one was just a bit quicker walk f6
you okay aid
and at the end it's a question how white
it's able to promote the pawn
the trick is he always this f3 check so
on let's say white would try to promote
the pawn then there's this move and the
pawn gets lost something like like this
here and this is a draw obviously
without a pawn you cannot win this so
this is the trick the c7 move needs to
be considered very cautiously sf3 is the
counter play so he played through b7
first look at King f6 and now King of
three blocking in the pawn and now the C
pawn is ready to move but let's say what
happens rupee seventh takes and c7 and
now you would say okay black resigns
right but they're still eetu as the
funny counter play if white would take
now f3 then you would get the pawn and
manage the draw but in fact after you -
of course white can under promote
tonight so we have the rare occurrence
and a top world-class Grandmaster game
of an under promotion to a knight of
course it was Czech so this is the the
big point like needs to react to the
check and after this white captures the
corn yeah and now we have the funny
endgame of three minor pieces two nights
and one bishop against the single bishop
and two pawns that the pawns are there
is actually rather unimportant I would
say because there's affirmed it located
yeah and this is thinking relatively
easy with the minor pieces just get to
positions where they maneuver blacks
King to the side
at the end like I'm where I manage to
put up some nice net yeah with all these
squares being controlled by the knight
and the bishop and we see a proper
mating procedure here coming yeah and
all squares are covered in h2 bishop
here and now like just has these two
squares and the problem is simply that
in this kind of position it's simply
made into you cannot avoid the following
king h1 Knight takes and of course it's
no stalemate there's some Bishop left
and the bishop needs to give up one of
those two squares so it's not f2
checkmate and yeah very funny finish to
this game actually prominent resigned
one move firm or two moves before the
checkmate so a very very original kind
of end of this this great fight yeah you
need to really aim at Miami in a camera
phone declining this this draw this draw
offer with the repetition on one one one
twenty it was 23 and play on obviously
it involved some risks I think Kramnik
had for a long time a fine position but
he really made a big mistake with his g5
move possibly and very likely actually
in
in time trouble and after this la cámara
got a strong attack and the only way to
diffuse to the tech was allowed the
Queen exchange with this transposed into
a basically lost endgame so a big win
here for Nakamura himself I mean as a
kind of individual personal success to
beat Kramnik I think he also beat him
for the first time in a classical time
control game I'm not 100% sure but I
think this is the case that played a
number of draws and he lost games but I
didn't I'm sorry he won one Kings Indian
I'm sorry he won once in the Kings
Indian in dog would become like
incorrectly sacrificed apiece so it
wasn't the first win but still win
against one of the all-time greats he
was a world champion after all chrome
dick so um yeah and also a very big win
for the US team beating Russia and now
I'm yeah the the hunt for the gold the
overall gold medal in the loop here is
wide open
they have been nine rounds place now of
total of 11 rounds so two rounds left
and there are I think four teams if my
memory is correct now tied with 15
points which is the USA China Russia and
Armenia and yeah it's it's wide open two
rounds left
lots of those teams have played against
each other already so I'm not 100% sure
about about the following round but I
can try to look it up I'm sorry let me
just check round 10 round 10 dome is
played tomorrow on Friday the 8th okay
yeah okay the u.s. is playing China
which is of course super important both
of 15 points and then Russia will play
Argentina who some artists for their way
up
- to the top and me Nia plays the
Netherlands also solid a nice run so um
yeah I don't know how to tell but of
course if China against the USA we'll
have a winner
this team will have a huge huge chances
of course - to win the tournament I'm
not 100% sure about them the tiebreaker
rules I must admit I would need to look
it up
what what's exactly most important here
in terms of tiebreaks yeah but solo I'm
very very interesting finished now of
this tournament we can look forward to
two more exciting rounds yeah thanks for
watching this great battle and yeah I
think I'll put on a new video tomorrow
right after round 10 to keep you
informed what has happened all right
till then